today we are continuing our kindness
one-on-one series with Steve Hartman in
it we share stories built around
kindness and character and the people
who have mastered those qualities
today's lesson is listening Steve and
his kids introduce us to a man whose
greatest gift isn't what he says out
loud but his kindness when he's not
speaking
good morning I'm here with my daughter
Meryl hi everyone today we're talking
about not talking or otherwise known as
listening Emmett at the dictionary desk
how would you define this word
for our purposes here I would Define
listening as showing respect with your
ears
with your ears getting Fancy with the
definitions
yeah listening is actually one of the
best ways to show someone you care or to
make friends which is kind of
counter-intuitive like how could
listening help you make friends it's
it's to know someone's listening that
somebody cares that somebody will always
be there for you and like to know that
their opinion matters exactly to prove
the point let's turn now to our library
of Great American role models and pull a
story guaranteed to make you a better
person if only you listen
in St Petersburg Florida when the Sun
rises Al Nixon sets for his impromptu
therapy sessions are you surprised at
what people tell you
not anymore
Al isn't a trained therapist I've been
concerned he actually works for the city
water department he's dismissing but in
these early morning hours he's a trusted
Confidant and counselor to whoever
passes by and I wrote to him and I said
Renee rutstein is a regular he knows
everything about me did you feel weird
sharing all your secrets to a guy on a
bench no because he'll never judge me
and he always shoots me straight he's
not judgmental and he takes you for who
you are Bernadette Dorset Mills says she
has never met a wiser man he's like the
guiding force at the same time I don't
hear you talking a lot no I just see a
lot of nodding like you're doing now
listening is the number one skill all
mankind needs to know how to do very
well
a skill he has clearly mastered when Al
started coming here seven years ago the
therapy was for him he needed a quiet
place to clear his head and the last
thing he wanted was to hear other
people's problems
but then a woman he'd never met told him
something he'll never forget she said
every day I see you
I know everything is going to be okay
and that made me realize that when you
speak to someone or you smile
you let them know I value you and people
pick that up when I walk by sometimes
you know I don't even get a chance to
chat with him because there are other
people waiting in line
in appreciation for always being there
Al's faithful put a plaque on his bench
to a loving and loyal friend and a
confidant to many forever and always
that was powerful
how can such a simple plaque be that
powerful when you expect to someone you
matter to me
they gave you back what you gave them
everyone needs an owl
you too
fortunately I don't just have anal I
have the Al he joins us now hello how's
everyone doing we're doing great thank
you if people started talking less and
listening more how do you think it would
change their lives
in my opinion I think you learn when you
speak
how far away do people come to see you
in different
Parts why do you think people come from
far and wide
they want selfies and they want to sit
on the bench they want to actually be on
that [ __ ] with me do you think it helps
you as much as it helps them yes I think
it helps in the sense that I know
what I meant to do yeah to know your
purpose is
practically the meaning of life
you're a beautiful man I know it
probably makes you uncomfortable to say
as many words as you had to today but we
really appreciate you talking with us
thank you very much and kindness matters
in one of the greatest ways you can show
kindness
is to care enough to listen
great thank you so much Al you're
welcome Steve
you know I find it helpful sometimes
when I'm in a conversation to think of
how many words I'm saying versus how
many words the other person is saying
and I tried to keep it to one word for
me for every two words for them and I
think if everybody did that the world
would be a Kinder Place wait a second
that wouldn't work out mathematically
not everyone can do that
he needs to know when to listen
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
I mean there's so much wisdom tucked in
that when you listen you learn more than
when you're talking I think that's true
and that's all I have to say about that
John Tower told me just listen say
nothing I'm just listening